They indicated that there would be
control. They identified that there
would be limitations on the amounts of
digital euros that individuals or
businesses may hold in their digital
wallets. And they noted that it was an
effective holding holding limits were an
effective tool and it would be included
in the design of a digital euro. So they
signaled to us subtly each of these
central banks that there will be
control. Yeah, Eva, correct me if I'm
wrong, but I understood it as that that
they will literally take Yeah. take the
money from you if if you're not using
it, right? Yes. Yeah. So, and it will
and they can set it to expire within 30
days. That's so weird. And then if you
the goods, it will evaporate. So, in
other words, we're going back to
communism. Like, everybody is equal.
It's al it's communism/socialism
at this point. like everybody's equal,
everybody you can't be rich, you can't
be wealthy because you can't have money
in your account. CBDC on the one hand is
control of your money. Tokenization of
assets is control of everything else.
Wow. And we know that at some point um
we're going to lose in the great
controversy as we read it in Revelation
13. those who are loyal to God and obey
his laws and worship God aren't going to
be able to buy or sell. you know, we're
gonna we can expect I think the way we
wrap our head around this mentally is to
see the changes that are going on, see
the architecture that they're building
to enforce Satan's no by no cell policy,
but read the Bible and and really um
improve our relationship with God and
with Christ and have that daily
devotional time because God doesn't want
us to be afraid of any of these things.
M we should count it a blessing to have
to lose our money and all of our things
for Jesus. So, Revelation 13, Mark of
the Beast, that also includes, of
course, no buying and selling. And I I
think that we are starting to see this
this growth towards this idea of no
buying and selling. It's coming closer
and closer. Mark of the Beast is coming
closer and closer. And so, we need to
talk about this, what's actually
happening so we can be prepared. CBDC,
Central Bank Digital Currency. We're
going to talk about it with Eva and
Heidi Tomkins. You guys run the uh CBDC
watch and you guys are also from the
Wisdom Pearl. Maybe you can talk about
the Wor Pearl a little bit at the end,
but first CBDC, why does this matter?
Why is this connected to the mark of the
beast? How are we gearing towards this?
So um I realized during the pandemic
that I I work in the financial markets
uh I'm a lawyer. I practice law for 20
years in New York uh before retiring um
to practice in the financial markets and
because of my work in the financial
markets I watch the central banks very
closely. I have to see what they're
doing, how they're setting interest
rates, what they're doing because what
they do affects the markets. So during
the pandemic, I started to see this push
towards central bank digital currency
and I looked into this and for me God
showed me that this is really the
perfect architecture for Satan's no buy
cell policy. It's it's fully
programmable central digital currency.
For those who don't know what it is,
it's fully programmable, fully traceable
digital currency that is issued by a
government or central bank. And because
it's issued by one authority and it's
fully programmable, fully traceable,
fully surveillable, they can see all of
your transactions in real time, monitor
them all in real time. They can track
them in real time. They can tax you
instantly. they can institute negative
interest rates which would be a
deduction from your uh from your balance
which would be in your digital wallet.
So they really need uh a few things to
in you know to have this type of system.
They need a high quality digital ID
which they're pushing to real ID right
now as well. Yeah. and they need a
digital public infrastructure which is
central bank digital currency or a
similar uh stable coin some sort of
digital currency and then they need a
widespread sharing of information.
So the reason why it's a threat to
liberty is because with central bank
digital currency, you really need the
government or the central bank's
agreement that you should spend that
amount of money in that transaction at
that location for that particular item.
They could really program your central
your CBDC so that it can't work uh to
buy certain foods and goods that they
might not want you to buy. So that it
can't work in certain locations.
um so they that it can't work for a
specific amount. Um they can they could
program it however they want to to
elicit the behavior that they want for
people. So that's fully controllable by
the central bank that issues it. So if
it's controllable and traceable you said
and program programmable is this
something that they're creating like
it's not crypto or NFTTS or anything
like that right is it like original like
they are making it
correct okay the central the it's
digital currency that's issued from a
central bank as a liability on its
balance sheet so when the central bank
issues money it's a liability on its
balance sheet no different when um it's
digital, it's a liability on their
balance sheet. So when the central bank
issues you the money, they control
everything about it. It's fully
programmable. They can control how or
when it is spent, um what it can be
spent for, how much you can have. They
can set an expiration date on it, which
they really like. They could put a
30-day or less expiration date on the
currency, forcing you to convert it to
goods. I actually really like that
feature because it allows the central
bank to control the money supply that
much more efficiently.
So, the reason why this is the threat to
liberty is because if the government
were to mandate certain um
that certain medical practices have to
be taken or or medical procedures
certain need to be taken. They can turn
off your money if they don't if you
don't comply. They could turn off your
money if you don't if they don't like
what you post on social media. They
could turn off your money if they don't
like your religious practices. They
could turn off your money for any
particular reason. If let's go back to
the lockdowns. If they wanted to keep
you in your house or enforce five minute
cities or 15 minute cities, it's easy to
do with central bank digital currency.
Your money won't work outside of that
radius. And it's completely paperless,
right? So yeah, completely paperless.
Huh. Wow. That's that's one way to
control.
What's really interesting is, you know,
during the pandemic, if we just reflect
back a few years, right? I mean, of
course, we've all used our debit cards,
our credit cards, you all bought online,
but notice that during the pandemic, you
know, everything was locked down, right?
So, you couldn't go. There was a period
of time here in New York, you couldn't
go to the store, and you certainly
couldn't go into a store if you weren't
wearing a mask, you know? And so many
people were forced to shop online
client. And so, you know, with people
shopping online, we saw during that time
a pullback from cash. And we saw that
many merchants were saying, "Okay, well,
we can no longer take cash. They didn't
want cash anymore. They wanted all these
digital transactions, which made things
convenient, you know, when we were under
that pressure situation or under that
pandemic situation." But and and so
people are much more used to it now. And
so, you know, you could almost look at
that as like a setup for, you know, the
next phase or the next stage, the CBDC
people are because I' I've talked to
people about I've actually uh when we
were setting up the listener pearl, for
example, we went to the bank and you
know, and I was interviewing banks and I
was looking at banks who, oh, you know,
participate in um the bed now, the Fed
Now, right? And so we avoided those or I
went to other banks that weren't
participating in Fed Now and I was
educating their employees about CBDC
because they knew nothing about it. And
I wanted to bid bank with a local bank
who was not going to be uh you know
swayed or so easily swayed into Fed Now
which was like you know like one of the
first steps leading up to the whole CBC
you know idea. And you know they they
just had no idea. But they,
you know, they recognized that, you
know, merchants were not wanting people
to use cash and wanting to use, you
know, more of your debit card and credit
card and all of that. And they just had
no clue about this CBDC thing. And some
some one of the one of the tellers was
saying, "Well, what's the difference? We
already use our debit card, our freight
card. We purchase everything during the
nerd online." And that's great that you
have that freedom to do it, but how are
you going to feel when you don't have
the freedom? And when the government's
telling you where you can use that debit
card or that credit card or when you can
use it or you maybe they don't like your
social credit score, they don't like
what you're posting on Facebook or
Instagram or Tik Tok or any social media
and they just turn off your money just
like that. And they were like, "Oh,
that'll never happen. That'll never
happen." But they were just clueless. It
was really funny actually. Yeah, I think
um for sure this has been a long time
coming. Um I'm in my mid4s and I don't
think I've used cash in 20 years.
Um you know, as soon as I could Yeah. As
soon as I could get a debit card and and
later a credit card, that's what I use.
And and people understand that the more
data is breached online, the more there
are security concerns. You know, you
should it used to be 2FA. Well, the a
lot of that can be intercepted, you
know, depending on how you're using it.
If you're having it come to your phone
because your SIM card can be hijacked.
Now, if you're using a a third-party
authentication manager like one password
or Last Pass or something like that,
then those codes can't be intercepted.
But now it's all a push towards pass
keys. You need your device for
biometrics because it's much safer than
just having your data, you know, all
available online. But you think of how
we've just been moving steadily towards
that for a long time. You know, this is
like not necessarily a new idea, but
think about it like in this country
there are um EBT, right? EBT is a a
debit form of payment that is issued by
a government entity to pay for food
items for people who are at a certain um
poverty level. Mhm. You can't use that
for just anything at the store.
It's only an approved list of goods that
can be purchased with that card. Is
there in a way it's already controlled?
So, in a way, there are already measures
in place to control the purchase of
various goods and services. Now, you can
see how people are already kind of like
that conditioned for this and they're
not and that's not to say that it's
always bad in every kind of situation.
If you're giving a benefit to somebody
who's in a poverty level situation, you
don't want them taking that debit card
and going buying lottery tickets. You
don't want them to go and buy, you know,
extravagant things or things where you
would find it wasteful, like for
example, cigarettes and alcohol.
Especially if they were able to give
that debit card to a minor and you know,
the minor goes to the store for their
parent. Let's say they're 17, they go
shopping. You don't want them to just be
able to buy anything. They need to be
able to come home with the groceries.
So, there are many forms that we
actually do this and we find it
acceptable. But the key piece is always
the freedom. like, can I do what I want
to with my money? Is it really my money?
So, so I'm thinking
the reason why I got you two on here is
because I was witnessing some
developments in the CBDC world, right?
And I think specific, well, we already
know China has it. We know that the
United States is working towards it.
Many countries are working towards it.
And it's interesting, United States is
working towards it because we we
understand from Bible prophecy that this
is where the mark of the beast is going
to happen first. Um link in the
description if you want to know why for
a in-depth Bible study on the mark of
the beast. But um but you know, we know
those things, but I I was witnessing
about Europe that Europe is very close
to actually establishing a CBC. So can
you guys give us a little bit of an
update of where things are at right now?
Well, sure. Absolutely. So there's a
couple websites that you can check to
track how CDC is developing around the
world. Right now there are most
countries most countries are pursuing a
CBDC in some stage in some form. Some
are in earlier stages of research and
development. Some are in later stages of
research and development. But there's
two websites that are very good at
tracking this. One is the Atlantic
Council. Uh the Atlantic Council has a
CBC tracker. If you go to the
atlanticounsil.org,
you can find their CBCC tracker. Um the
other is uh it's called CBCtracker.org.
So those are two different websites and
both have similar maps as to what what
countries are pursuing it and what
stages they're pursuing it. The
countries that are pursuing a CBDC
represent about 98% of global GDP. Wow.
So this is truly a worldwide global
thing and it's all being pushed by the
bank of international settlements which
is the central bank above all of all the
other central banks. They have so of
unity. They are their own country. They
can't they can't be controlled by any
government or country or global group.
they're their own entity and they
oversee all the other central banks and
they've been pushing for this for some
time and in fact there was a statement
that was made by the general manager for
the bank of international settlements
his name is Augustine Carstens and back
in October 2020 so this is five years
ago uh almost five years ago he was
talking about central bank digital
currency and he said we tend to
establish the equivalas with cash there
is a huge difference there. For example,
in cash, we don't know, for example, who
is using a $100 bill today. We don't
know who is using a thousand peso bill
today. The key difference with CBDC is
the central bank will have absolute
control on the rules and regulations
that will determine the use of that
expression of central bank liability and
will have the technology to enforce
that. So that's from the Bank of
International Settlements general
manager back in October 2020. They
they've been pushing us and hurting us
towards this such a bank digital
currency and putting pressure on
countries around the world to institute
this type of system because the central
bankers want to have this control. I
think it's a situation where we see with
many things is there are two good things
that have opposite outcomes being pitted
against each other. Mhm. So is
everything that comes with CBDC bad? No.
There's a lot of things that we probably
would welcome and appreciate. Mhm. I
mean, if you're really want to be
cracked down on things like drug trade,
well, if you can't purchase anything
because there's no cash or the cash is
being taken into all the banks, you
know, because it's not in circulation
anymore, how are you going to buy stuff
like that, right? So, all of a sudden
now it's it's trackable. Now, I guess my
question for you as I sit here and think
about this is there are dozens of
cryptos.
most of which are probably decentralized
and there isn't
a tracking system in place etc etc for
example like Bitcoin one of the reasons
I know some people wanted to put Bitcoin
in place as essentially the currency of
the United States is because it still
maintains some of that freedom aspect if
you're just using Bitcoin so how does
Bitcoin come into play because it's it's
skyrocketing as people see this is the
next ticket this is what we need to
invest in. Um, it's it's worth a lot
because we say it is, but how does that
pit against the other? Because there's
still a lot of Bitcoin out there. I
mean, I don't think it's been fully
generated. There's still some that can
either be generated or haved and people
still have that as an asset. So, how do
you control that?
Well, uh, there are working to control
that and I'll explain how. So, Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies, they're
essentially, you can think of them as
freedom currencies in that no one's
forcing you to buy them. You can buy
them unless you have a government that
says we're prohibiting the purchase of
Bitcoin. And some some countries did do
that for a little while. They tried to
prohibit Bitcoin. Um, you can buy
Bitcoin, you can have Bitcoin. Um,
however, Bitcoin has been hijacked in a
certain sense. The SEC has ruled that
Bitcoin is commodity. while all other uh
cryptos are securities. Now, why did
they do that? There's not really there's
not too much of a difference. It's it's
a cryptocurrency like any other
cryptocurrency, but they ruled that it
was a commodity.
Since then, large tech funds uh like
Black Rockck have created derivative
products around Bitcoin. There'll be
Bitcoin ETFs, there's Bitcoin futures,
there's options. And in this way,
they're going to if they don't already
have the the control, the ability to
control the price of Bitcoin, they will
be able to control the price of Bitcoin
because it's the same thing with silver
and gold. Silver and gold should have a
much higher value than they actually
have, but they're being controlled
through the paper products around them,
the derivative products around them,
PTFS, um, futures and all that options,
all that sort of thing. So there's gold
enthusiasts who say that gold and silver
should be much higher in value. The same
thing I think I see them doing to
Bitcoin, trying to co-opt Bitcoin with
these derivatives like the futures,
ETFs, options and that sort of thing to
keep the price down or to control the
price in in any way they want to. Yeah.
The other thing is it one of the largest
Bitcoin holders? Yes. Yeah. Actually,
this the um yeah, actually the um
justice department is one of the biggest
Bitcoin holders just because many
wallets. Yeah, that's another thing that
I was wondering about too is if
governments or even large corporations
that kind of have lucidized to
governments kind of snatch up the
majority of it. Essentially, it is
controlled because it's not yours. Well,
and that's also interesting that the
justice department specifically owns so
much of it, knowing that in Revelation
13, you know, those who will not take
the mark of the beast are those who are
going to be persecuted. How can you
persecute somebody or put him to death
unless it's enforced by law and the the
government plays a role? Yeah. I want to
say that the FBI was a large holder of
Bitcoin like 10, 15 years ago. Like they
invested early. So I was like, why is
the FBI investing into Bitcoin? Like
writing was on the wall, right? Yeah.
Wow. Yeah. Well, I'm also thinking of,
you know, speaking of the mark of the
beast and and um what that's all about.
We know that if you read it carefully,
it's about worship, right? It's in the
text. And so um I'm wondering cuz some
people might hear this and be like,
"Yeah, but this is all like about
finances and about money." And sure, the
revelation says no buy or sell, but how
do you connect that to the idea of
worship of well, there's some religious
entity involved, but it seems far
removed for some people. Religious
entity or religious worship and
finances. How do you connect those two?
Well, once they control your finances,
they really control you. That's the
idea. And what we've seen in this
digital system is sort of, you know,
coraling us into this system of control.
It's really, if you listen to uh
Katherine Austin Fitz, she's a she's a
brilliant uh investment banker. She
calls it a control grid. This digital
system is really a controlled grid. If
you can control people's money, you can
control their behavior. Wow. If you can
control their assets, you can control
their behavior. So you may not see a
connection with religion now, but once
they can can control your money and your
assets, they could really control any
part of your behavior. And we know
prophetically that that will lead to
worship and the line controlling worship
and like it's not during a pandemic,
too. When you look at the places that
were prohibited, the places that were
forced to close, churches were on that
list and they should not have been.
Churches should have been one of the
last places, you know, that should have
closed, that should have caved. But so
you when people say, "Oh, this has
nothing to do with religion. It's just
finance, etc., etc." Well, let's just
look back a couple years. You know, you
could go to the liquor store, you know,
you could go to a strip club or anything
like that. You know, you could do
anything that you wanted to do, but
churches were shut down. And the
churches that didn't shut down, that
stayed open, were heavily heavily
persecuted. Why is that? Yeah, it's a
good point. Anyone who thinks that this
is not tied to religion, I would beg
them to ask that question. Why is that?
And break
[Music]
Jacob
and he for you Israel.
I will make him a pillar in the temple
of my God. And he shall go out no more.
I will ride on him. The name of my God.
Be strong in the Lord and in the power
shall strength. He shall mountain
like heels. He shall run and not
but by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of God.
A lot of it starts very slowly. You
know, when this when this starts, it's
not like all the sudden the the the grip
is on. Mhm. It's it's like a squeeze.
Yeah. Right. Y So when you when it
starts I mean Yeah. It's going to flip
over and then you're going to be like
okay it is what it is life has happened
and this is the way we have to deal and
life will probably go on at some normaly
for a while and it's only until the
issues rise up that it's going to that
we'll feel the squeeze. So but you're
saying you're expecting that eventually
well we'll all just be forced to go with
a CBDC digital currency but but it's not
like it's going to h overnight be an
issue. So, my my perspective, I think a
little differently than some people. Um,
I know a lot of people talk about a
financial crash.
I'm not necessarily a proponent of that
when I look at Bible prophecy. That's
just me. Not saying I'm just saying I
don't think that has to happen for
control to happen. Yeah. Because we
already see control happening without
that. It's true. So, for example, like
with like your credit cards and debit
cards, like all that stuff is already
trackable. It's already traceable. And
this is almost just like flipping a
switch and saying, "Well, it can only be
digital, right?" Well, at that point, I
mean, most of my life, probably like
most of your life, if you live in a
first world country, you're probably
dealing in mostly digital anyway. It's
just numbers in your bank account. Yeah.
That's it. Like, I'm not taking cash
out. I'm not putting cash in. I mean, if
I am, it's rare. Like, I still use
checks every once in a while, like
probably some of you, but I'm even
getting to the point where relatives lay
like I I want to say like I just had two
kids graduate from high school and a
couple of them were like, you know what,
just sending money through the mail.
There's been too many envelopes that
people have cut into in their experience
and they're like, I'm just not sending
it through the mail anymore in cash or
check. You shouldn't send cash anyway,
but they wouldn't even they didn't even
want to send a check. They're just like,
"Can I just sell it to you?" And I'm
like, "Yeah, I mean, it makes sense."
Yeah. And that's the thing. A lot of it
will make sense. Yeah. But the part that
doesn't make sense is the part that what
everybody is going to wake up to some
point down the line when it comes to
moral issues. That's when it's not going
to make sense. But then it's going to be
too late. It's going to be too late when
people realize. Yeah. Yeah. So and
they've already signaled that there will
be some control especially in Europe. So
uh Denique you mentioned that you saw
some developments in Europe with CBDC.
Mhm. CBDC in Europe they are in the
preparation phase. Preceding the
preparation phase was the investigation
phase, the investigative phase. But in
the preparation phase that ends in
October 2025, but back in October 23
when it started, they had just concluded
a two-year investigation phase. And in
page 12 of their summary report, they
indicated that there would be control.
They identified that there would be
limitations on the amounts of digital
euros that individuals or businesses may
hold in their digital wallets. and they
noted that it was an effective holding
holding limits were an effective tool
and it would be included in the design
of a digital euro. So they signal to us
subtly each of these central banks there
will be control Yep with central bank
that's messed up. Yeah. I mean, at least
they're open about it. I Yeah, they're
open about it, but it's like, well, what
is that number? And and you know, you
think of like you're a business, it's
like, well, how much am I going to be
able to have in my account? And then
where's the other money go or do you
even have it? Like all these kind of
questions are in my mind. Does it sit in
your bank and then you can move it to
your wallet, you know, and if they you
can only if it's throttled? Yeah. That's
that's unnerving. Yeah. Yeah. What if
you go to the store and it's like,
"Well, I needed more." Yeah. But you
don't have it. Mhm. Mhm. Yeah. Eva could
correct me if I'm wrong, but I
understood it as that that they will
literally take Yeah. take the money from
you if if you're not using it, right?
Yes. Yeah. So, and it will and they can
set it to expire within 30 days. That's
so weird. If you don't the goods, it
will evaporate. So, in other words,
we're going back to communism. Like
everybody is equal. It's al it's
communism/socialism
at this point. Like everybody's equal,
everybody you can't be rich, you can't
be wealthy because you can't have money
in your account. I mean, we've heard
what I think it was the World Economic
Forum that said like you will own
nothing and will be happy. Mhm. Because
they'll be controlling everything
including your money and and how much
you can buy and eventually what you buy
will also be owned by them. Right. In
the end, nothing is yours. Not your
money, not your goods, not your time.
Yes. Not your freedom, not anything. And
a lot of it is like that now. And you
don't mind. So, for example, all your
streaming services, you actually don't
own that content. That's right. That's
right. They own it. I don't care if it's
Spotify, Paramount, HBO, whatever. They
own the content. You're just essentially
leasing it from them through the stream.
Mhm. Right. So, we already live in that
system. Yeah. Even Apple is like
announced that they're having a uh you
know, where you're essentially leasing a
MacBook where you pay X amount of
dollars per month. Like, why buy a new
one every year or every couple years?
Like, you could just lease one. Well,
then you don't really own it. It's
theirs. Mhm. But it's convenient for you
because you don't have to put out as
much money up front, right? Right. or
necessarily even long term if you and
then you like the idea of I always have
the latest and greatest.
Right? So there's that trade-off that we
find ourselves appreciating like with
all the music and stuff. It's just like
well I have every song I could ever
want. Well it is this is something I've
talked about before in this show. It's
it's the idea of the frog and the pop.
You just slowly turn up the heat and you
don't you don't just go overnight like,
"Hey, so we're doing all everything in
cash and all of a sudden you know
nothing." It's like this slowly turn up
the heat, slowly introduce all these
other concepts. I mean, Satan is hugely
deceptive. He's smart cuz it's not all
bad. It's not. No, I I like the idea of
Spotify where I don't have to like pay a
dollar for every single track like you
used to do with iTunes, you know? Mhm.
So, it's it's actually cheaper to listen
to lots of music that way. I liked it.
But now you as you're talking about it,
yeah, it is slowly introducing this
mindset. Yeah. Well, you're going to
have to learn how to play guitar if you
want music.
I'll be playing guitar when I'm like
hiding in my cave fleeing. Yeah. Yeah.
Start now. It's the convenience factor
that lures everyone in. Yeah. It's truly
the And like you said, there's going to
be things that we will so willingly
accept, things that people will love.
Like if you think about it now, like you
know, buying a house, I mean, you know,
a closing is, you know, like 60 to 90
days in most cases, right? Um, you know,
it's it's probably pretty rare to close
in like 20 to 30 days, although it might
happen. But now, you know, you're just
going to be able to like flip the
switch, you know, and and a lot in the
past, SA has talked about the
tokenization effect. You know, we see
the things that you guys just discussed,
but behind the scenes, they want to
tokenize all of our assets so that it's
literally just, you know, doing this
transfer, doing that transfer, and
things are going to be instant. And
because we as people have been
conditioned in society for convenience,
you know, these things are going to be
really really great. And you know, so so
that phrase, you know, that the World
Economic Forum made, you'll own nothing
and be happy about it. You know, they're
going to make life so convenient that
people who are dependent upon
government and money and their
treasuries on earth and uh you know and
they're looking for temporal things, you
know, will be happy because they're
going to make it so convenient. They're
going to make everything at your
fingertips within their limits of
control.
But the you know the the uh the
implication is that if you don't comply
then you're not going to be happy right
if you don't comply if you don't live
under the government system you're not
going to be happy. But the beauty as
Christians, as five believing
Christians, is when we read the book,
we, you know, when we read the end of
the story, we actually are going to get
to a place where we're going to be able
to own nothing and be happy about it and
be completely dependent on God.
Unfortunately, the world doesn't know
that way or Yeah. Yeah. Well, you can
just see how painful
it will be Mhm. to try to move out of
that system unless you're prepared
mentally, spiritually. Yeah. Correct.
Yes.
And and so my question to you guys is as
we're seeing this progression, as we're
seeing that we're headed toward the mark
of the beast on all aspects, like CBDC
is just like one of them many facets
that shows it that we're close. But um
how can we be prepared financially,
spiritually, emotionally, mentally? How
can we be prepared so that when this
comes it doesn't take us unaware?
Well, I just want to touch on something
that Heidi just mentioned and you just
mentioned as well. So Heidi was talking
about tokenization
of all assets. That what she's referring
to is a plan by the bank of
international settlements that they
released in their annual report on June
20, 2023. It's their annual report was
titled blueprint for the monetary system
improving the old and enabling the new.
And it's a plan to tokenize all assets
all priorly held assets on a global
unified ledger. So that's your house,
your car, anything that is registered or
insured can be tracked would be assigned
a digital token. And so CBDC on the one
hand is control of your money.
Tokenization of assets is control of
everything else. Wow. And we know that
at some point um we're going to lose in
the great controversy as we read it in
Revelation 13. those who are loyal to
God and obey his laws and worship God
aren't going to be able to buy or sell.
you know, we're gonna we can expect I
think the way we wrap our head around
mentally is to see the changes that are
going on, see the architecture that
they're building to enforce Satan's no
by no cell policy, but read the Bible
and and really um improve our
relationship with God and with Christ
and have that daily devotional time
because God doesn't want us to be afraid
of any of these things.
We should count it a blessing to have to
lose our money and all of our things for
Jesus. Amen. That means we're going to
be on the right side of the great
controversy, not on the wrong side. If
you want to buy or sell and accept the
mark of the beast and worship the beast,
well, you'll be able to buy or sell, but
you're going to suffer eternal death. So
that the choice is really between
eternal life and eternal death. Are we
loyal to God or are we loyal to man? And
and the way we wrap our heads around it
is let's be loyal to God. I mean we you
know we love God. We we want to go home
to heaven. This is not earthly home is
our home. Our home is elsewhere.
Christians know that. Yeah. I was going
to say and leave the results to God.
Don't don't build up in your mind I
guess all the dreadful scenarios because
certainly yeah that could happen. But
when we do that we also limit God and we
say you know God won't do anything for
me. There are many promises in God's
word where he promises to keep us in
hard times. So don't dwell on all the
negative like, "Oh, I'm not going to be
able to get groceries and, you know, I'm
going to starve to death and all these
kind of things." It's like, you have no
idea what God has in store for you.
Amen. So, let God worry about that part.
You just worry about being faithful. You
remember how Elijah was fed? You know,
this was not really common. It was not
conventional. It was not conventional at
all. But God still it was outside of the
CBDC system.
Can't control. Yeah. Speaking of Elijah,
by the way, uh for many people don't
know that we have a uh scripture song
channel uh where we generate AI
scripture songs and one of them is about
the story of Elijah being fed by the
ravens. So this is a perfect time for
someone to memorize that when they get
to that time. Keep that promise in your
heart and remember it when the time
comes. Amen. Amen. Yeah. Amen. Yeah. The
Bible tells us our bread and water will
be sure. Yeah. We and we shouldn't have
a spirit of fear about any of these
things. If anything, when I see these
developments, you know, everyone's a
little bit frightened when you see them.
And you nobody wants to be controlled by
your government or told you can't do
this, you can't do that. But it excites
it excites me a little bit because it
shows us we are truly living in the last
days. Now is the time to live for Jesus.
Now is the time to do God's work. You
know, God is waiting for his people to
have Christ's character and, you know,
be have that type of of, you know,
sinless, selfless character. Amen. You
know, let's do his work. Let's be his
hands and feet and really do his work in
these last days. Amen. And how merciful
is God that he's he's showing us these
things, right? We we read, you know, to
the Bible verse that, you know, God does
nothing without revealing his secrets to
his servants, the prophets. And so the
rules of the game are that you know even
the enemy has to show his courage from
lunchtime. Right? So we see these things
developing and during this time this is
that you know testing investigative time
where God is giving us the opportunity
to free ourselves from you know debt and
to get out of debt or free ourselves
from you know the you know addictions
and and the strong ties that have been
built towards our possessions and our
houses and you know furniture and cars
and all these things. You know, God,
we're obviously not going to be able to
take all these things with us and
there's going to come a time soon that
we're totally separated from them. So,
now you mentioned, you know, how do we
prepare for this physically, mentally,
spiritually, emotionally. Now is the
time that we really need to be as we're
drawing closer to the Lord, detaching
from the world and the things that we
have in this world that God has just
left us for a period of time. M the
things we have in this world, this is
the way I explain it to my children is,
you know, the there's the option of how
you view an object. It's either a tool
or a toy, right? So maybe I have an
iPad. Well, is it a tool or a toy? If
it's a tool and I can use it to
help me be efficient, do God's work, all
these kind of things, great. If it's a
toy and then it's a distraction and it's
not helping me do anything useful or
productive, right? So, I have to think,
is it a tool or a toy? And then the
other thing that I that I will tell
people when I'm out speaking is I'll
I'll ask them
when Shadrach, Meshach, and Abednego
were about to go into the fiery furnace,
um
the Bible doesn't mention any other
people
from Israel
that day. Mhm. Why not? Like, what were
their names? because they weren't the
only one there in the plane of Dura.
There was a whole group taken captive
from Babylon. You don't know the names
of them because they essentially weren't
faithful. You can think of it as their
names were written in the Lamb's Book of
Life, right?
So, they concentrated on remaining
faithful and they left the results up to
God. By all intents and purposes, they
were facing certain death. like nobody
comes out of a burning fiery furnace
alive, right? But they didn't limit God.
They just said, "We're going to be
faithful. We'll leave the results to
God." And then God did something outside
of the system, right? Outside of what we
view as possible. And God can do the
same thing for each one of us in any
difficult circumstance as long as we
remain faithful to him. Leave the
results to God. I like the quote uh God
has a thousand ways to provide for us of
which we know nothing. I really like
that quote. Yeah, that's true.
Absolutely. So, can you guys tell us a
little bit more about your CBDC watch
and then also the wisdom pearl and you
said before we start recording you have
another conference coming up.
Yeah, sure. So, um the CBDC watch is a
Substack that I write. It's Revelation
1317 CBDCwatch.substack.com substack.com
and that is under the umbrella of the
wisdom pearl which we're also involved
in. Sure. So the wisdom pearl is an
organization that myself and my ministry
partner Alaj started and we you know we
had been doing conferences before the
pandemic. They were mostly health
related in a health food ministry called
Heidi's Health Kitchen. But you know
during the pandemic we thought this is
our opportunity to really step things up
because a people need to be prepared for
the things that are coming and for the
judgments that will come upon this world
and to be prepared to stand before God
during the investigative judgment. So we
we really uh sought to bring uh more of
of the spiritual component into our
conferences. And so we created the
wisdom pearl and and our our
organization is based on a text actually
in Isaiah 33:6. It says, "And wisdom and
knowledge shall be the stability of thy
times and strength of salvation. The
fear of the Lord is his treasure." So as
people you know are have so much
treasure on earth. We our desire is to
bring people to um a higher spiritual
plane to bring people to understand the
Bible through history and the current
events that are going on in our time.
And we have endeavored to influence the
influencers because we really want to
spread the gospel and the free angel's
message with rapidity because of the
times that we're living in. So we
organize conferences. We have two a
year, one in the spring and one in the
fall. And our sixth conference is coming
up and it's called Blue Star. We're
going to be dis discovering the plan of
salvation through astronomy and
counteracting some of the um beliefs
that people have that are not found in
the Bible. Cool. Awesome. And where can
they find you? Do you guys have a
website? I think you have a YouTube
channel as well, right? Absolutely.
Yeah, we are on YouTube. You can search
the wisdom pearl and people can find us
online at the wisdompearl.org.
And of course, Eva has got a speaker at
all of our conferences uh except for the
last one, but she she'll be at the next
one as well because we really feel this
topic
um you know for for people to understand
the implications that will be built
around worship is so so important. And
so this is something at every conference
we're hearing more and more about this
so that people can be prepared to stand
for the Lord no matter what the cost.
I'm really passionate that I don't want
anyone to be lost because they're too
tied to their money or their things. We
should not be lost because we're tied to
money or things. Um, and you know, God
gives us these things that we have in
our life and the our possessions and our
income and they're all his and we're
stewards of them, but we shouldn't be
tied to them. We shouldn't lose focus.
We should be faithful to God throughout
all of this. Yeah. And be able to let go
of these things. If we're too tied to
them, then that's our God. It's become
our master.
Correct. That's right. Yeah. Well, we'll
make sure to drop a link in the
description for all of you guys'
resources and also for I think it's
called Heidi's Healthy Kitchen, right?
Your your um healthy chocolate company
that supports you guys' ministry. Yes.
So, we'll make sure to drop all those
links in the description, but I just
want to point out to the viewers at home
for those who want to know more about,
you know, again, the mark of the beast,
we've got a podcast, an audio only
podcast episode on that. We've got a uh
full video on who the antichrist is,
which I would recommend you watch that
first and then what the mark of the
beast is that you really understand how
this ties into the CBDC and um yeah,
another video on there as well, who the
pilgrims believe the the antichrist was
and the pilgrims who came to the United
States and the Mayflower. And then also
we have a video on the 666 and no
conspiracy theories, no guessing game,
just straight from the Bible. What is
666? What does it mean? and how
everything ties into our salvation in
Jesus.
If you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos. And drop
a comments below, and we'll try to get
back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]